let's take a look at this colts roster
because post julio jones trade the
titans and the colts were both plus 110
favorites to win the division courtesy
of our friends at the points bed sports
book the jaguars and the texans nudged
them to the back this is colts and
titans battling it out to win the
division just like last year
offensive line eric fisher in quentin
nelson still there ryan kelly mark
lewinsky braden smith
give me the best way to categorize that
position group well i think like a top
10-ish group in football certainly in
the top half of football but there's
just that one glaring question mark
right that left tackle spot avoided you
know that's been voided by anthony
costanzo now who's it going to be they
did a great job in signing eric fisher
but
you know i don't think he's going to be
ready to go at the start of the year at
least i wouldn't expect
but man when you talk about quentin
nelson you know ryan kelly that's a
pretty damn good you know center guard
combo there braden smith is a good right
tackle um so it's one of the better
units in football for me i don't know if
it's like the blue wall like we talked
about maybe two three years ago when it
was really special but it's still a
dominant group
and it's a huge difference for carson
wentz all due respect to the eagles it's
something he's never enjoyed before that
kind of ability side to side and you saw
the stats up there the difference
between the eagles offensive line and
the colts offensive line last year that
could allow carson wentz to you know
have some time right to find receivers
maybe buy some time with his feet if
need be less pressure fewer hits fewer
injuries better performance by carson
wentz receivers ty hilton back after a
4a into free agency michael pittman
paris campbell at receiver as well jack
doyle and moe allie cox at tight end
uh best way to describe that group i
mean solid with the potential to be
special i think that's the way i would
kind of look at it you know michael
pittman jr we saw some good things from
him you know paris campbell is the guy
the unforgotten like the forgotten guy
from from two years ago he's been
battling injuries but he's got a really
exciting explosive element to his game i
mean he was a 4-3 guy and a second round
pick and we've seen a lot of second
round picks you know dominate football
the last few years so to me it hinges on
him we know t y hilden what he is he's
still really good he's not the star he
used to be
you know tight end play solid uh but i i
think you know yes this is like a real
good
middle of the pack group mike i don't
know if you see it the same way where if
like paris campbell comes through you go
oh they could be semi-special and
dangerous in what they do
yeah i don't know
i don't know i mean there was a reason
why they were mentioned so early on in
the julio jones sweepstakes yeah right
t.y hilton's been around for 10 years
now um i and and he was available for a
while to anyone who would have wanted
him and he's had some great performances
i'm not taking anything away from him
but someone else would have snatched him
up i think if he was still viewed as one
of the top guys in the league
uh
they need pittman to keep developing um
you know it's
you know as matt casey's telling me this
really isn't scaring anyone when you
look at that list of names and uh
i i think that that they would benefit
if if someone would come available uh
and again the julio jones ship obviously
has sailed and i don't know who else is
out there that will just suddenly
whether it's a trade whether it's a guy
who gets cut because he got a big salary
but i feel like chris ballard's got to
be thinking
man it would just be nice to get
to just get one guy one guy whether a
guy who can take the top off the defense
not that you can just dial up
you know a menu and get a guy like that
but i i feel like they're one body away
a good recognizable name a proven
commodity i feel like they would use
that not necessarily julio jones and i
think they were smart to not go get
julio jones because chris ballard
recognizes i got to pay this guy at some
point but
but but somebody yeah let's say the
let's say the rams decide not that you
know you can't really trust desean
jackson to stay healthy but no but i
know what you mean i'd feel better about
that receiving core if they had desean
jackson even with his health issues
that's where well that's where i got
into like the paris campbell
conversation he could be that guy but
like you know this has been something i
think you've heard me say over the last
year with the colts it's and i think
you're bringing it up and i think it's
it's spot on you know
they they need that difference one more
difference maker on each side of the
ball you know i think that's a real
thing it's a lot of good
they just need that you know one great
aspect to get you over the edge to you
know oh it's a close football game and
let's not always have to depend on our
system and everybody doing the right
things it'd just be nice to have a guy
that can make a play and win the damn
game for us you know that's to me where
they miss a little bit on both sides of
the ball and that's where paris campbell
is going to be big and you're right you
know it's it's uh something to watch for
with their football team but i do also
think
if you take into the running game
and nahim heims of what he can do in the
past game it makes that group a little
bit better than than maybe we uh want to
give it credit for
desean jackson has played eight total
games the last two years paris campbell
has played nine
two scary yeah two games last year seven
games the year before so yeah staying
healthy is the key you mentioned the
running backs jonathan taylor ended up
being great last year there was concerns
he had too much wear and tear coming out
of wisconsin where i think he had 11 000
yards in one season and 850 carries
uh
naheem heinz a nice change of pace guy
great acrobat as well marlon mack yep
came back because he had that torn
achilles tendon week one right and it's
a shame it was his contract year and i
know they've had high hopes for him but
that is a hell of a three-headed attack
there between taylor and mack and you
throw in heinz you can do some special
things out of the backfield and it does
make your receiving core better right
because defenses have to worry about the
guys in the backfield there's no doubt
you got to worry about this aspect of
their football team with that o line and
then this guy's a game breaker
that's what we saw as he got comfortable
during the year last year at the end of
the season i mean he got into the one of
the best most explosive running backs in
the game i mean he he can go
70 yards right through the middle of the
defense outrun everybody so it was good
to see him come along that's where it's
you know you're excited for carson wentz
because you sit here and talk about
these things and go man frank reich
pretty creative system they got a good
old line man three good running backs
got a little everything you know what
wence doesn't have to do it all by
himself but man mack is similar to
jonathan taylor to where if he got
banged up you got marlon mack to come in
you don't miss a beat there and nahim
hines is you know your special jitterbug
guy there to where yeah i think when you
take it into totality you look at that
offense and go it's got a chance to be
something that receiver question i think
you bring up is is the most prevalent
one
last year they made the move to get
deforest buckner trading the first round
pick to the 49ers and then paying
buckner that's helped transform the
defense you know other than darius
leonard and i know you you've got a lot
of faith in quitty pay guy that was
drafted this year right there there
aren't names that just fly off the page
but the unit all together
it feels like it's catching up to the
offense this has been an offense heavy
team for a long time it's skewed toward
the offense that's been their way
the defense
seems to be on the verge of becoming
more than it's been i think so
you know buckner was huge for them last
year and for a long period of time i
think he was you know in the defensive
uh player of the year conversation
and we saw when he missed two games
their defense fell off but like you know
yeah it's i think him and like you said
darius leonard are the only two
household names you know there's a lot
of great depth they got everything you
need from that standpoint and a lot of
good
it's just like like we've seen the great
defenses have more than just a deforest
buckner and a darius leonard the great
defenses have another two three names
you can add to that right and that's
where the colts are gonna get or need to
get to and that's where yeah who is it
who's going to join the list there you
know is it somebody in the secondary i
don't know you know they're
just but darius leonard we know how
awesome he is they need one more
difference maker on that d-line and
we'll see if quiddy pay can be that guy
coming out of michigan he is a physical
twitchy explosive
pass rusher i just he's he's kind of a
he doesn't fit the mold of great pass
rushers mike you know is that outside
linebacker going to be great at
everything is he gonna go get
double-digit sacks every year i don't
know i gotta see it to believe it first
uh but but i think he's gonna be a
definite good addition to that defense
and make some plays and be disruptive
nonetheless
you know
there's a guy in the colts defense who
may be very happy about the arrival of
julio jones in tennessee and that's
xavier rhodes
rhodes had a history of shutting down
julio jones when rhodes was with the
vikings and jones with the falcons and
last year when the vikings didn't have
roads jones torched them
now they're going to get reunited and
this isn't an you know
an a-list cornerback receiver battle at
this point right
but
uh rhodes is back rhodes was so much
better last year than he had been in his
last few seasons in minnesota and uh i'm
looking forward to watching julio jones
and xavier rhodes go at it because i i
remember seeing them go at it many times
from 20 what 13 14 through 2019. he's
got that like he's got the physical size
and strength to at least match up with
the julio jones that's where like julio
is just so crazy talented because he's
fast like a guy that's much smaller but
has the strength of like a tight end
getting off the line of scrimmage so
that's where a guy
like xavier rhodes is certainly
important and yeah he was
way better last year than the two years
we saw a previous to that to minnesota
so hopefully that consent continues
rakisson you know pretty damn good kenny
moore one of the better nickel guys in
football you know safeties i love the
julian black blackman guy i think he the
way he can run around fly he adds great
value to their team but i don't know to
me it's still that's that's a little bit
of a question mark of a group there to a
degree you know i just look at that
group and just go
okay it's a big game it's the colts or
some of these other really tight i mean
the colts of the chiefs are one of these
other high octane afc offenses
i don't i don't have great confidence in
this secondary's ability to play
man-to-man that's been my big question
about them for the past two years and
something i will continue to sit here
and watch and evaluate with them
let's see how it plays out for the colts
though but colts titans afc south and
whoever emerges is the winner of that
division
who knows maybe a team that can go deep
into the postseason in 2021
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports